Kylie Jenner claims some alleged baby  bump pics were photoshopped and has a  junk-food filled girls trip with her  sisters the 20 year old reality star  took to Twitter on Sunday after a photo  surfaced that appeared to show off her  baby bump let me tell you Twitter is  really it's a great tool while kylie has  yet to confirm her rumored pregnancy she  did insist that those images were  photoshopped the pics were obtained by  x17 online and the agency maintains that  they are quote 100% real meanwhile Kylie  and her sisters Kim Kourtney Khloe and  Kendall went out together on Sunday we  really had the best time ever and  documented their girls trip on social  media including snapshots inside of a  convenience store and a massive mound of  junk food Cheetos and Pringles and  Donuts oh my the 20 year old also shared  this full body shot in a baggy  sweatshirt with Khloe who a source tells  ET is also expecting with her boyfriend  Tristan Thompson don't-ask-don't-tell  policy  [Music]